[Music]
we're going to tom in miami florida tom
welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys how you doing doing great how
can we help
so
i uh i know the
father husband said to me what i want to
do i just need some guidance long story
short i have a uh
2021 chevy suburban
that is um
almost paid off i have probably about
10 grand on it
i could turn around and sell it given
the used car market
for about 70. and
given the financial situation of our
family it would really help with um
i haven't done a very good job
uh leading our family financially
we're getting better
but um
you know it would put us and that's the
only debt that we have is that it's the
rest of the vehicle
i'm i've been talking to my wife about
selling it and that'll give us a fully
funded emergency fund i'm severely
behind on retirement to the point of i
haven't started yet i'm 37 years old
and with the scope of
the economy and everything and just with
you know everything going on
i feel like uh you know it's my duty
that
i gotta i gotta get this turned around
somehow my wife loves the car granted i
mean it's it's a beautiful vehicle
but we have three kids a two-year-old a
four-year-old and uh almost six-year-old
and i can imagine now i'm neurotic about
it it's causing me a lot of stress
that the car is gonna get destroyed
and the value's not gonna be in it
and so i'm just i don't know what to do
that's my question well number one dude
um
i this is this is one of the this is
this
i've taken a few brave calls today we
recorded several episodes of my show
earlier today and i talked to a brave
man and
you two are also brave
you're brave for looking
at one scary place and that's the mirror
and saying
um i need to make some changes i got
three little ones and i just i'm looking
at the news and the world's changing and
i gotta do i gotta do better dude i
wanna high-five you i'd hug you if you
were here i'm proud of you man that's a
hard place to start is in the mirror so
good for you number two sounds like
you've crushed a whole bunch of other
debt is that right
yeah we've we've done well we
we actually we bought a house in 2015
and we were very fortunate to accrue a
lot of equity in it
um
hey i want to stop you real quick you
know what you're really
you're really good at
when things are bad
you take the blame
and when things go well yeah you say we
or you say we just got really lucky on
this one i suck but we got lucky i want
you to own the good and the bad okay
yeah yeah is that a fair trade
yep okay so let's start owning the good
stuff so you bought a house in 2015 the
market appreciated you made a great
purchase and then what
uh we moved into a brand new home which
were blast beyond belief um
you know and
yeah i mean we've we've done some
upgrade you know we had to put a fence
around it you know so the kids wasn't
flying the neighbors pond and you know
but we we you know we depleted pretty
much a lot of the equity with the down
payment of the home and you know all the
other stuff that we had to do to it and
you cashflowed
yeah you cashflowed at all yeah okay
yeah
so to get to your question um
i don't have a love affair with cars
george i know you do so maybe you're i'm
just kidding you don't either me and
john both drive trash cars that are
worth a tenth of what that suburban so
if it's me
yes i'm with you i'd sell that car i
would go buy a great highlander
something that i could tote three kids
around in that also i could grow with
for the next decade
and then i'm setting everybody up
the other side of this conversation is
less about my wife loves the car
that that that's okay those
disagreements happen throughout marriage
of all time
i'm more concerned that i don't know
that she's heard your heart yet does she
know that you are scared
um yeah
kinda
okay here's what i want you to do
i
i have a tendency a lot of my friends
have a tendency to have these
conversations and their math problems
look at this we could sell this pay off
this buy this and be done with this
i want you to sit down once you take
your wife out for a meal and i want you
to look her across the table and say i'm
scared about our financial situation i'm
ashamed of how i've how i've led us here
and i want you and me to be together in
this making the next steps and i want to
sell this car and it's going to bring me
peace will you join me with this